JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
Hello, everyone.
I'm going to go ahead
and get started.
Welcome to our session.
Thank you very much
for coming.
I realize there's free drinks
after this, so we're going to
try to keep you entertained
until then.
We'll talk about supercharging
your mobile game with YouTube.
And I would like
to introduce my
co-presenter Corey from Unity.
He is working on Unity
implementation with a number
of partners.
So I wanted to start with
this photo that I
found on the internet.
As you can tell, it was
taken a while ago.
There's a few really excited
mobile gamers.
This photo was taken at
a gaming convention in
Vancouver, Canada.
The question that popped into
my mind when I saw this is,
what would it take to excite and
energize your gamers, your
players, your customers
equally today?
Well, if you look at some stats,
there was a study done
two years ago.
And 95% of gamers that spend
significant time playing games
watch user generated
content on YouTube.
So these are gaming clips.
Actually, the number for
trailers is 94%.
So more people watch user
generated content than the
highly produced gaming
trailers.
In fact, there's several
companies already taking
advantage of this trend.
So, some of these titles that
I'll show you will probably be
familiar to you.
Trial Xtreme 3, FIFA 13 has
video upload capability so you
can share your gameplay directly
from the game, and
then the granddaddy of them
all, Talking Tom.
This is an application that
has really taken great
advantage of video sharing.
So in that app, you can create
a video that's both a nice
virtual pet, a type of
app, as well as a
self expression platform.
So this is what we'll
talk about today.
We will show you how you can
take a sample Unity game that
we build for this purpose, and
then integrate YouTube API in
order to share the gameplay
with the world.
YouTube has one billion users,
so there's a billion potential
customers out there.
And then we'll show you both
the upload and playback
capability--
how that can be integrated
into a Unity game.
So really, the only thing you
have to do as a game developer
is focus on building
a great game.
That's it.
So first I wanted to show you a
little demo of the game that
we have built for
this purpose.
So here's my game, and the
objective of this game is to
shoot these gas cans as
fast as possible.
And I'm pretty bad at it, as you
can tell, but I'll try to
do my best.
One more.
Oh.
I got 12 points.
All right, time is up.
So the next step--
I just had this wonderful
score of 12 points.
I would like to watch
myself play this
game, so here's a replay.
Pretty amazing.
I rock.
So what I do next is, well, I
definitely want to share this
gameplay on YouTube.
So I'm going to hit the YouTube
button and let this
processing take place.
What this means to you is,
imagine you were playing an
awesome game--
some sort of warfare simulation
and with your best
friend, and you just blew up
his or her Abrams tank.
You can share that achievement
on YouTube, and then claim the
bragging rights for the
rest of the week.
Now, I would like to introduce
Corey, who will take you
through the process of creating
games with Unity, and
then he will discuss some of
the plugging opportunities
that exist within the
Unity framework.
After that, I'll take you
through the process of
actually integration between
YouTube APIs and Unity.
So over to you, Corey.
COREY JOHNSON: Thank you.
Hello, everyone.
My name's Corey Johnson.
I'm a field engineer at
Unity Technologies.
This is Unity circa last fall.
There I am, just in case
you were doubting me.
I'm going to take you through
what Unity is, what we're
about, and then kind of give you
an overview of our editor,
just so that we have some
context when Jarek talks about
his plugin later.
I apologize if you already
know Unity.
We're going to stay high level,
but I just want to go
really, really fast.
And if you don't know Unity, I
apologize, because we're going
to go really, really fast.
But myself and my illustrious
colleagues are in the sandbox
on the third floor in the
Android section, so please
feel free to follow up.
So what is Unity?
Well, we're a cross
platform engine.
We come with an editor,
which is a tool to
create 2D and 3D content.
We believe we have the best
tool in the industry.
We believe that we give you a
rapid learning curve and rapid
iteration times.
We have a mantra of build once,
deploy anywhere, meaning
we're, again, multi-platform.
Our mission statement is to
democratize game development,
and that means that we want
anybody out there who wants to
build a game-- whether an artist
or an engineer-- to be
able to build a game.
And that attitude has led to our
tooling, and it also led
to an enormous community, which
I'm going to talk about
in a second.
When I say everywhere,
I'm just going to
quickly define that.
We're currently at 13 different
platforms, and more
on the way.
We even have Union, which is
platforms that you may not
even know you want to
be on yet that we
help get content to.
So as you can see, we're fairly
prolific, and if you
want to be there, we're probably
there for you.
A little bit about
our community.
1.8 million people
use the product.
400,000 monthly actives
every month.
5 million hours of creation
Enormous.
From the hobbyist all the way
up to triple A studios.
One of the things we did to
democratize this is build an
asset store, which is a
marketplace for our users to
share content, whether it be
tools that they built in our
customizable editor that we just
didn't get to, or if it's
awesome artwork that
people need.
So like, for me, I'm
an engineer.
I can't do art, but I can
go in and buy awesome
environments or a knight
to run around my game.
One of the features that we use
is called Native plugins.
We're going to talk a lot about
it today, so I just want
to give you an overview
of what they are.
So Unity uses Mono for
scripting, so that means you
can run your game scripts
across platform.
But what plugins let you do is
call native code to whatever
platform you're on from
your game scripts.
For this talk, we're going to
focus only on Android, and I
will point out this
is a pro feature.
So first, there's two
ways to do plugins.
The first is native and
the second is Java.
They're actually
interchangeable.
I'm going to talk about Native
first, and then a little bit
about Java.
So here is an example of some
code that's like C code that's
a minimal plugin.
All it does return a value.
All I need to do is put this C
file and build it into a .so
file using the Android NDK, and
I need to place it in my
project plugins folder,
which I'm going to
show you in a minute.
To call that code-- and that
code can be doing, obviously,
a lot more complex things--
all I need to do is, from my
game code, use interop
services, annotate my function
definition, and
then call my code.
That simple.
For Java plugins, it's a
little bit different.
We use the JNI to interact
with your Java
class that you build.
You can build a .jar file using
Eclipse and the Android
development toolkit.
Again, you just build a .jar
that contains all your
classes, make sure you check
the Is Library button, and
then place that inside
your plugins folder.
We provide--
because you have to do some work
with the JNI to discover
your methods and then
invoke them--
we provide some wrapper classes,
the Android JNI and
the Android JNI Helper.
And on top of that, we build
another layer of helpers,
which is Android Java Object and
Android Java Class, which
allow you to not only automate
the whole process, but we also
cache those lookups
so subsequent
calls are a lot faster.
So instead of showing you Java
code for the plugins, I'm
actually just going to show
you an example here.
And then Jarek's example
is going to show
a lot of Java code.
So on the slide, the two lines
that you see that are not
commented out are what you need
to do to make a call to
get this hash code string.
All the commented out lines are
what you would do if you
had to do that natively, so it
just kind of gives you an
example of how much work we
save for you and how much
prettier your code can look.
That's about it with plugins.
What you do with them
is up to you.
Here's some pro tips.
When you're dealing
with Android--
and obviously, you have the
whole world of the native
platform at your fingertips--
you can do things like add
activities and do things with
stuff that we don't normally
request permissions for.
So in order to use that,
obviously, you need those in
your Android manifest.
Now, usually we generate one for
you, but you can take that
and modify it, add whatever you
need, place that in your
plugins folder, and just drop
it right next to it, and we
will automatically use
that one instead.
That way, you don't have to
rebuild it every time.
One thing, whether it's for
yourself, whether it's for
future users, customers,
whatever, teammates--
you saw there was some work,
annotating your function
definitions, making
the NJI calls.
It's really easy to just drop in
another code file that does
all that work for you and just
exposes the raw APIs you want
your users of this--
the plug-in-- to actually see.
We are dealing with
managed code in
your user game scripts.
When you go down to the native
level, obviously you're
native, and we have to marshal
that data-- any data that you
want to deal with--
back and forth.
So be aware that there is some
penalty costs to this, so you
may have to weigh the benefits
of where you
want to do the work.
We're talking a lot about video
today, for obvious reasons.
I just want to point out some
function calls that we're
going to use later, and
what they do, and
explain a little bit.
The first is on render image.
This is a call back to you, so
you can basically react to
whenever all the rendering
is finished
for your render target.
This means that everything is
done, and in this case,
normally, what we would do is
Michael Bay up the screen like
here, and add some bloom effects
and lens flares.
All we need to do it for
to get a replay is
just copy the frame.
Similarly, on audio filter
read gives you a chance--
every time we read a piece of
audio data that we're going to
send into the audio processor,
you get a chance to customize.
You can squelch it, make
yourself sound like Darth
Vader, whatever.
Again, in this case, all we're
doing is using that
opportunity to copy that
data so that way, we
can encode it later.
When you're dealing with a
plugin that deals with your
frame time, you're going to
want to be able to sync up
your plugin work when you're
going to get the frame versus
when Unity's rendering, because
you don't want to grab
any frame data in the middle
of when it's writing to the
frame buffer.
Wait for end of frame is an
object you can yield to in
your co-routines, and that will
make sure that when you
come back and that code
executes, you're at the end of
the current frame.
And that just helps keep all
the syncing together.
I'm going to switch over
to the editor now.
Awesome.
So this is Unity Editor.
This is where you're going
to build your game.
The first thing I'm going to
talk about is our project
window right here
in the middle.
The project window is literally
a mirror of what's
actually on disk.
It's all your models,
meshes, textures,
sound files, et cetera.
You can literally go and look
in on the file system, and
it's going to look
exactly the same.
You'll see here I have this
plugins directory.
Plugins is one of our
reserve words.
We look for that folder and then
treat things in there as
plugins, so we know
how to build them
into your final game.
And then you just say,
I want an Android.
And as you can see
here, we have a
custom Android manifest.
And then we have a bunch of
libs that Jarek's going to
talk about later.
So not everything in there is
going to end up in your final
build of your game.
On the left here, we have a
hierarchy window, which you
can see here to the right
of my screen.
This represents everything
that's represented in our
drawing screen.
So that's like my wall here.
I can move it up and down and
break his game, and do all
sorts of fun stuff.
And here's where you build your
layout of your game and
all that stuff.
So we are a component based
engine, which means that
everything in our game engine
is an object with components
that add behavior.
So over on the right, we have
the inspector window.
The inspector window shows us
all the components on there.
So you can see that currently,
I have the wall selected.
We can see that it has a mesh,
it's a mesh render, it has
some animation to it, it
has a box collider.
And all these do is tell the
engine different things, and
have different widgets where
we can customize how our
engine reacts to
these objects.
If I select our main camera,
we'll see that we have a bunch
of scripts attached to it.
Now, to get custom functionality
into your game,
you create scripts.
Our scripts, again, are
Mono, so it can be C#,
JavaScript, or Boo.
We ship with Mono Develop, so
you have everything you need
to develop a game already
installed.
Inside here, we have--
it looks like I picked
the audio one.
That's fine.
Inside here, we have the
OnAudioFilterRead, and you can
see all we're doing is checking
to make sure that
recording is active and then
passing that data to a convert
and write function.
Similarly, we have a similar
function for video, where we
have OnRenderImage, where all
we do is do a little bit of
logging, and we are making a
copy of our frame buffer.
I mentioned earlier to have
rapid iteration times.
At any time, you can hit the
Play button located at the top
of the screen there.
And we go ahead and allow
you to play your
game, and test it out.
So I can test out the force of
the tennis balls that we're
shooting out, et cetera,
et cetera.
Awesome.
So that's a little bit, so when
Jarek's in there later
and showing screenshots, you
kind of know what you're
looking at.
I'm going to pass it back
to him now, so he
can talk about, maybe.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: OK,
thank you, Corey.
OK, so Corey took you through
the process of creating a game
with Unity.
And if you're a Unity developer,
then really, the
only thing that might be new
for you is the way you
integrate plugin capabilities.
If you haven't tried Unity
yet, I encourage
you to try it out.
This is a lot of fun.
Now, what I'll cover next is,
OK, now how can we integrate
video upload and video playback
capability into the
game to really take advantage
of the opportunity out there
that we highlighted earlier?
So first, let me switch
back to my demo.
And the gameplay that I was
showing you earlier when I
scored an amazing amount
of points, I'm actually
ready to share it.
I think it's really awesome.
I'm just going to hit Upload.
And at this point, we're
actually uploading the video
to YouTube.
I'm actually generating a
notification to show the
status of the upload.
While that is taking place, let
me walk you through what
actually happens.
So for this, we are using WebM
as a video container, VP8
codec, and Vorbis codec for
video and audio respectively.
Tomorrow morning, there's a
talk about VP8, so if you
would like to learn more,
I highly encourage
you to check it out.
And we're also launching VP9.
There's another talk about the
next generation of this
technology.
But let's just take a
step by step look at
what is involved here.
So we started with this awesome
Unity game, and then
what we actually need to get out
of the game engine is the
audio and the video frames.
So this is what is illustrated
on this diagram.
We're getting the video frames,
passing them onto the
VP8 encoder.
We're getting the audio frames,
passing through the
Vorbis encoder, and then use the
WebM container in order to
create a video file for us.
Once that file is created, we
use the YouTube data API.
In this case, we use the YouTube
data API version 3 to
upload the resulting
video to YouTube.
The YouTube data
API is RESTful.
It's fairly straightforward
to use.
For Android, we use the Java
client libraries, so you don't
actually have to write
any HTTP, HTML, HTTP
JSON parsing code.
Now, in our example, we built
a Unity plugin in order to
take care of the video
upload from Unity
and the video encoding.
Couple of hints while developing
the plugin.
Corey mentioned the Android
manifest is something that
Unity generates by
default, since it
actually creates the APK.
However, if you're building any
additional activities in
your code, or need additional
permissions, you need to merge
that into the manifest
created by Unity.
So the way to do that is, first
time you build a game in
temp staging area, you will
get an Android manifest.
And then you edit that and
copy that over into the
plugins directory, and
you're all set.
Another thing to pay attention
to is that plugins are
actually required to be built as
Java Android libraries, so
you actually need to be careful
about resource merge.
And really, the only thing that
is somewhat inconvenient
is that if you're used to the ID
base lookup up in your code
directly, inside of the plugin
while you're running in Unity,
you should actually use the
functional way of looking up
or the procedural way of looking
up the resources.
Other than that, it's just
regular Android development.
Now, Corey mentioned some of the
methods involved in video
and audio capture, so I'm just
going to quickly go through
what we did for this demo.
So we actually attach two
scripts to the camera--
one script responsible for
video capture, the other
script responsible for
audio capture.
So let's start with the audio.
We are actually capturing the
audio at 24 kHz frequency, so
this is the raw PCM data that
you're going to be receiving
in your application.
You can actually configure
that using
AudioSettings.outputSampleRate.
So this is something that you
can configure in Unity.
And for video, I'm just
using 10 frames per
second right now.
Unity has a nifty feature.
You can actually set the replay
frame rate, and this is
different than the actual target
frame rate at which
your game runs, precisely
for this use case.
So if you want to record a video
of the game, you can
actually set the capture
framework to whatever makes
sense, and you do operate
within the number of
constraints that we'll touch
upon a little later.
So for audio recording, and
Corey highlighted that when he
pulled up MonoDevelop to show
you a snippet of the code.
We use AudioFilterRead.
So this is the callback that
is invoked by Unity at the
frequency that you define using
the mechanics from the
previous slide.
And what's passed to you is
really raw PCM audio, and this
is what we'll pass on
to the encoder.
Then for video--
and this is, again, something
that Corey highlighted--
the continuation here, yield
return new wait for end of
frame, that allows you to be
notified when frame rendering
is fully completed, at which
point you can actually turn
around and read the complete
frame back.
And there's a number of
approaches to this.
We experimented with
a few of them.
They all have different
tradeoffs.
Here's one.
So this is the approach where
I'm actually using texture 2D
to read back pixels at a
resolution defined by you, so
you can actually generate a
video at a lower resolution
than the original.
And this is, again, if you
want the video file to be
relatively small, so you
can be shared from
mobile devices quickly.
You can actually read the frames
at smaller resolution.
Another approach is to use the
glReadPixels, so you can read
it directly from the frame
buffer using the open GL
glReadPixels.
And this is an example of
another implementation that I
did using Java.
So that is actually invoked from
within the Java plug-in
to obtain the frame buffer.
So that's the capture step.
Once the frames are captured,
so the raw audio, raw video,
we need to encode it.
And for that, we're actually
using WebM and VP8
plus Vorbis for audio.
So let's talk a little bit
about how that is done.
And again, just referring back
to our reference diagram,
we're actually at that stage
right there in the middle
where we obtain the raw frames,
we are passing it down
through the encoder.
So one thing that is very useful
on Android is our WebM
engineers actually have created
JNI bindings for the
encoder, both the Vorbis encoder
as well as the VP8
encoder, and you can fetch that
from code.google.com.
That is a JNI wrapper.
It has dependencies on a few of
the native libraries, but
this is what actually provides
you a really nice performance,
and this is what we used
in our application.
So a couple of things to
consider when you're actually
using this.
So think of this as a kind of
nice object-oriented way to do
a video encoding.
So if you're not comfortable
writing C code, but you're an
Android developer, you know
Java, well, now you can encode
video, and you can do
that very easily.
So let's just walk through the
basic building blocks.
Audio encoder, there's a
couple of classes-- the
encoder configuration and the
actual encoder, a video
recorder, again, the
configuration, and the actual
encoder, and then the WebM
maxing capabilities so that
you can write the compressed
audio and video frames to a
container, and then end
up with a single file.
And here's an example of how
this looks in practice.
So we start with the byte array,
which is basically the
PCM audio that was given to us
by Unity as a part of the
script attached to a camera, and
then similarly for video,
we read that video from
the frame buffer.
And then we construct--
ultimately, what we want is
an audio frame and encoded
packet, which basically
represents the encoded audio
and the encoded video.
And the way that is obtained
is we actually pass the raw
audio bytes to the Vorbis
encoder, pass the raw video
bytes to the VPN encoder, and
then we use the maxer to save
the audio and the video frame.
That takes care also of
synchronization, so you don't
really have to do any
work in that area.
And what you get back
is a video file.
So here's an overview,
again, of the objects
that we just discussed.
So encoder configurations, both
for video and audio, the
actual encoders, the tracks
representing the audio and the
video part of the WebM
file, and the maxer.
So this is kind of the way I see
it as an object-oriented
way of doing video encoding.
And I really like it, because
I think it's very
approachable.
So for those of you that would
like to do a little bit more
work in this area, but have been
intimidated by having to
deal with a bunch of native code
and large libraries, this
provides an abstraction that
is very easy to use.
So once we have the video and
audio, the only thing
remaining is the
actual upload.
And the way we do that is using
the YouTube data APIs.
I'm using the YouTube
data API version 3.
So in order to access that,
you need to register your
project in the developer
console.
One thing to note is we are
uploading the video into the
user's account.
Therefore, we must obtain a note
of permission from the
user for our application to
act on his or her behalf.
And the way that takes place,
there's a little
bit of magic involved.
It actually works very nicely.
The only thing you need to know
about is that when you
register your project in the
developer console, you need to
supply a fingerprint for the
key that you're going to be
signing the application with,
and you have to tell Unity to
use a specific key storer or a
specific key to sign your APK.
And once you do that,
everything
just works like magic.
So we know on the server sides,
our API back end notes
that hey, this is your
application that is generating
these requests, so you don't
actually have to change any
code for this.
And then the upload process,
when I was showing you a
couple of hints, don't
block the user
waiting for the upload.
You can just do that as a
service, and then use a
notification to indicate
the progress.
And then, use resumable uploads,
because if you lose
connectivity, which is, in
fact, very likely at
[INAUDIBLE]
right now, this should actually
resume automatically.
So here's one video that I
created a little earlier.
Let's just play it.
I'm going to switch to
the mobile device.
So remember the notification
that I was popping up as a
part of the video upload right
now indicates that my video
has been successfully
uploaded.
Watch the video on YouTube.
So when I click it--
let me just select it--
I can see the gameplay
right in my game.
And I'm going to tell you a
little more about how that is
implemented as well.
But before that, just a quick
note on authorization.
I mentioned to you that we use
OAuth 2.0 in order to upload
the video on behalf
of the user.
And to implement that in your
Android application, you can
use Google Play services.
So we're using GoogleAuthUtil.
Makes it very straightforward
to implement the old flow.
And really, the only thing you
need is to remember about the
scope that you're going to be
requesting from the user.
So in our case, I'm using
YouTube Read Only, because I
need that in order to check
on the upload status.
And I'm using YouTube Upload,
which is going to grant my
application the right
to upload videos.
And that is reflected here by
this popup that is generated
by the Auth for Google
Play Services.
And then I was just showing
you a while ago how the
playback in application
playback works.
So the reason why that is useful
is earlier today, you
have learned about the new
capabilities that will be
launching in the gaming area.
So personally, I think
leaderboards and achievements
are very cool, but I want
a video to prove it.
So this is one use case that
you can implement is if you
have the upload capability, you
could associate or keep
track of these achievements and
leaders, and show the most
interesting footage from your
users in the app itself.
And for that, you can use the
YouTube Android Player API.
So this is an API that we
launched a few months back,
and as I was showing you
earlier, it has the capability
of high quality in-app
video playback.
There's very little work that
is required in making that
happen in your application.
Really, all you need to do is
drop in this library here,
YouTube Android Player API.
This is a small client library
that actually relies on our
YouTube app to do the actual
video playback.
So it's very robust.
It has all the capabilities that
you see in the YouTube
app, and you can make that
available inside of your own
app that is running inside of a
Unity game using the plugin
capability.
A couple of things to note.
The YouTube Android player API
requires a developer key that
is slightly different than the
dev key that we used for the
old uploads.
And then we may prompt you to
actually upgrade the YouTube
app on the user's device.
So if the app is out of date,
because the user hasn't
updated it, or it's not set
for automatic updates, we
actually generate this
error service
version update required.
Typically, that doesn't happen,
but this is how we can
make sure that the latest
capabilities or bug fixes are
actually made available to the
user when they try to use our
YouTube API to do video
playback inside
of your Unity game.
And then our transcoding
pipeline takes a little while,
especially if it's high
quality video, and we
transcode it to a number
of different formats.
YouTube data API v3 has
this nice capability.
You can actually check the
processing progress in order
to find out, is this video ready
to be shown on all the
platforms that YouTube
supports?
So I highly encourage you to
actually do that before you
do, say, software sharing.
So I was requesting G+
permission in my auth flow a
few slides earlier, and the use
case there is, once I'm
done with the uploading,
I want to
share it with the world.
But share it only once
processing progress indicates
that the video has been
completely processed, because
that means it will play on every
single type of device
that YouTube supports, all the
transcodes have completed.
So a few links.
If you'd like to learn more
about our APIs, go to
youtube.com/dev.
This is the link to the
repository that hosts all the
JNI wrappers for WebM, VP8,
Vorbis, and libyuv, which
allows you to do RGB to YUV
conversion, which is, again, a
little detail that we
don't get into too
much during the stock.
And then we are working on
polishing up this demo app,
and then we're planning to open
source it as well, so you
can try it out yourself.
So we hope that this capability
will excite your users.
Now it's 2013, so I figured
someone playing a tablet game
would be an appropriate way to
conclude this presentation.
And if you guys have any
questions, please
come up to the mic.
We have a few minutes left.
AUDIENCE: So this would do a
record as the user is playing
the game, right?
So what's the impact on the
performance that you expect on
the device?
Because gaming already consumes
significant horse
power on the platform.
And then if you're going to
record at the same time.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So the
question is, what is the
performance impact of
this capability?
Actually, the way this demo
app is implimented, we are
using attract where the gameplay
recording is not
happening at the same
time as the game.
So I am actually doing a
replay using the Unity
capability where you can
actually tell it to render
frames at certain speeds.
So there is no impact while
you play the game.
However, when you're actually
ready to share it, depending
on the device and depending on
how you configured it-- for
example, if you want HD, if you
want high quality video,
because those are parameters you
can pass to the encoder--
then the actual rendering of the
frames may or may not keep
up with the frame rate
that you get when
you're playing the game.
So there's an additional step
that involves basically
rendering the frames one by one,
and at low resolution,
low frame rate.
Right now, because I'm using a
pretty expensive way to fetch
the frames from the frame
buffer, at low resolution, I
can keep up with the frame
rate of the game.
At high resolutions, I can't.
However, that doesn't really
impact the gameplay, but it
impacts the replay.
Ideally, what we would want--
and we have a couple of partners
that do that for
other platforms--
in fact, there's one in the
sandbox, and one of them spoke
earlier today at the--
as you see, raising his hand.
So there's other approaches
to that.
They don't currently work
on Android, so that's an
alternative that can be used.
Hopefully we'll get to that same
level of performance, but
the impact right now is zero,
because the step of rendering
the gameplay is distinct
from the play.
AUDIENCE: So you also said that
VP8 and going to VP9,
again, does the developer kind
of pick the codec there?
If it's going to be VP8, VP9, or
is it YouTube that decides?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yes.
So the question is, what
does it mean now that
we have VP9, VP8?
So the good news is, you
don't really care.
So frankly, as long as you give
us the content in any of
the formats that we support
for YouTube ingestion, we
actually turn around and
transcode it and everything
imaginable that is required
by all the
devices that we support.
So we chose VP8, and we're going
to get into that in more
details tomorrow is because this
is open source royalty
free codec.
You don't have to pay
anybody any money.
any royalties.
You can do whatever
you want with it.
And it's a very liberal
license.
And it's open source.
So we find that this is a good
fit for these types of
applications.
The way YouTube works is, once
you upload the video, it will
actually take care of
transcoding into the formats
that are supported by
different devices.
So if a target device for
playback only supports H.264,
we'll use that transcode.
Then our Android player API,
which I demonstrated earlier
for playback, uses one
of these transcodes.
So it really is totally
transparent to the developer.
The only thing you have to know
is all these codecs have
specific requirements.
For example, VP8 requires a YUV
representation of the data.
That's why we have libyuv also
wrapped, so you can pass the
RGB data that you get from the
frame wrapper, convert that to
YUV, and pass that into VP8.
So there's a little bit of
knowledge that is required,
but I would say it's
pretty minimal.
AUDIENCE: So you answered part
of my question with respect to
the transcoding.
Now, for recording, I assume
it would also be H.264?
Because most of the devices,
they don't necessarily have
support for VP8 HD record.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah.
So we are using a software
encoder right now.
So the way this application is
built is the actual VP8 codec,
Vorbis codec WebM container is
shipped as a native library
wrapped through JNI and packaged
in the Android plugin
that is integrated
with the Unity.
So everything required to render
the video is included
in the game itself.
Android has the capability to
actually use the underlying
hardware encoder, and that
is typically H264.
Though, and again, this is
something that tomorrow's
session is going to go into in
more detail, the world there
is also becoming more
attractive.
But the nice thing about this
approach is there's no
dependency on the specific
device or a specific version
of Android, because it's just C
code that you compile using
NDK, and then the
JNI wrappers.
And it's also very small.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: All
right, so we have 20
more seconds left.
If there's one more question.
AUDIENCE: From the beginning.
I just want to ask, can we
record the normal Java screen?
I mean, the application screen
in Android, without
[INAUDIBLE]?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah.
Yeah, so the question is,
can you record the
application's screen?
And I believe the answer is,
for an arbitrary app, the
answer is no.
And typically, it's because
of sandboxing
requirements and whatnot.
So that's why this is something
that has to be built
into the application itself.
And this is really how
for PC games--
AUDIENCE: What are these
mechanisms for [INAUDIBLE]?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah.
So in this session, we actually
described how that
can be done with Unity.
And the mechanism for that is
Unity has integration points
to obtain the raw audio and
the raw video frames.
And this is what is actually
passed into our encoder and
uploaded to YouTube.
But it's application specific.
So Unity has this capability.
It relies on the
GL capability.
So this is something that
is app specific.
And if this is not clear, I'll
hang out after this.
We can go in more detail.
All right so.
I think we're out of time.
Thank you very much
for coming, and
please rate our session.